camilla and jaffet are in atlanta
georgia they're going to kick off this
segment for us
and good afternoon ladies and gents how
can we help
hey good afternoon hey how you doing oh
man this is so cool i mean
i love this i like this i hear it how
you doing
what's going on man how can we help
all right uh it seems like camila and i
are newly engaged and
uh we have a really really blessed
dilemma which is
uh should we uh invest our money in
a new mortgage or um basically pay for a
nice
wedding
this is like this is like the real life
show is
let's get some numbers how much money do
you have and let's talk about
all the options not just either or all
the options
yeah uh yeah are we talking about just
investments or uh well no the
the cash that you're asking us what you
should do with
yeah so it's a little bit short of 200
000
we have between us and that's including
retirement
and cash on hand savings and
all types of stuff kind of wrapped up
into that but we did that math about
two weeks ago we came up with about one
90 something or something like of that
nature
okay how much how much is not retirement
like actual cash yeah combined combined
between the two of us it's about twenty
three five
thousand twenty three thousand five
hundred dollars cash that we have okay
cool and what's your combined income
once you get married
that would be i believe that's
2 40. nice well done
okay how old are y'all can i ask that
question without 32
32 yo yo that's what i'm talking about
that's cool christy
okay now here go to question you know i
gotta ask this me being the money guy
you know you know what's coming next do
you have any debt
yeah they said it kind of excited
yeah how much we do yeah how much debt
do we have
i guess yeah yeah how much debt do we
have combined
uh for me i can speak for myself i have
about forty something thousand dollars
of student loans okay
um i i did work really hard last year
and paid off my car note
and um and my
consumer debt okay i do i did found home
in 2018
um and that has a i refinanced last year
so
my mortgage is probably about 240
something left on me cool i'm not
worried about the house so
uh just your only debt consumer data
says 40 000 student loans
yes that's correct okay what about you
bro how much debt do you have
all right so i'm i'm i'm got a little
bit higher but
uh it's student loans about 70 000
and then i still have 10 with just
around 9 10 000 on my car left which
i'll pay off this year
okay and so that combined is probably
around
110 000. yep yep okay do you have a
house or are you renting
no i don't have a house um i when
covered hit i mean i gave up my
um my place to stay on the folks to save
up and pay rent the goal was to buy a
house
but uh i did not do that yet and camilla
how much did you say your home is worth
i don't know if you said that
oh it's well knowing the market right
now
probably around 350. okay how much do
you own it
240 something oh
camilla you may not like me oh no
[Laughter]
okay all right chris you you want to
take a you you want to go after this
what you want to do chris
i'm going to tell you what i would do
yeah i'm curious if it's what you're
going to say anthony
okay so normally we say the house is the
last thing to
go but what's interesting about your
situation is you got a lot of debt
you do have a good income so this is one
option it's not the only option
but there's something i really
personally like about couples
renting the first year just because you
may not necessarily know where you want
to be
you're learning how to be a couple
you're learning how to be married you're
figuring out how to merge your lives
together and you guys in your early 30s
while you're very young
you also have 10 12 years of adulthood
of your way of doing things and so it
can look different merging your lives at
32 versus
22 and so um i don't think it's a bad
idea to consider
renting for your first year of marriage
selling your house
paying off your debt and then buy a
house in a year you know that's that's
one option it's certainly not the only
one
yeah but it's it's one i would consider
because of your unique situation
yeah yeah yeah i like it i like it all
right grab a pen and paper i want y'all
to write down
uh these things that me and chris is
going to give you um
put it or put it in your phone here's
the very first thing it has nothing to
do with money
uh one of the things i'm looking forward
to doing with my future wife is really
sitting down and identifying
our why what's the vision for our life
where are we going
what do we want uh is what what's what
does our legacy look like
what does the next three to five years
look like and so when you identify
that then it's going to give you the
energy to do what i'm about to tell you
next
all right so the number one thing that i
want to tell you all is to eliminate
your debt
100 so i'm not worried about purchasing
a new home
i'm not even worried about purchasing
and having a real big wedding if if i
was in your shoes
i'm saying okay cool baby we got to get
on a budget
and we're going to pay cash for this
wedding and you know what it's not gonna
be a twenty thousand
fifteen thousand dollar wedding you know
we're gonna get creative and
we're gonna make it a wedding that is
impactful for us
uh but it's not gonna be impactful for
our friends and for our families to be
all
no we need to set ourselves up to win to
go towards
our why and go towards our vision
so i agree with christy okay this is our
suggestions i know this younger
generation because you're in our age
bracket
and especially in atlanta they say keep
rental properties
so you can have passive income my
philosophy is i'm selling that house
with the with the revenue that i get
from the house i'm debt free
me and my wife are debt free we don't
have any kids
we have we're making 240 000 we're gonna
put
three to six months back in our seven
savings account
then we're gonna go ahead and go buy a
beautiful home down the road
within the next two years you all will
be debt free
sitting with at least 50 000 in your
savings account
and you can be a home owner with a clear
vision in a clear path for
your future and so that's what i
would honestly do y'all make great
income it's not going to take you a long
time to save up for your next house
don't think this is way far off it's not
we're making we're making the right
short-term
decision here yeah 240 000 y'all do
understand that the average household
income is less than 70
000 so you are like doubling a half that
almost triple
okay so you all are in a good place and
you're young
like me and christie okay so if you all
do
this and then start investing into the
stock market
um into mutual funds into your 401ks
you guys you all will be extremely
extremely extremely wealthy uh
let's do this kelly let's give them
ramsey plus yes great idea
yeah as a gift uh from christy and i and
a whole ramsay team here if dave was
here he would be super proud of you all
um and i want you all to uh go through
that
i believe if you all can do this now
when are y'all getting married
we haven't set a date yet but our
families are meeting literally this
weekend so once we do that that's going
to kick off
all the planning and stuff but you said
i was going to hate you but i love this
idea
what a pleasant surprise anthony has
pleased someone with his answer
it happens maybe once a month i'm glad
you are the lucky recipients
camilla you just made my day you know i
love it i
i love it thank you just made my day uh
just to hear you say you all like that i
mean yeah i'm telling you right now your
future is so bright the the
conversations
that will come out of you all taking
financial peace university through
ramsay plus that uh
kelly's gonna give you access to is
going to be amazing for setting the
foundation of how you manage money
moving forward not just getting out of
this predicament but moving forward how
you budget how you set goals how you
manage your money so i'm just i'm
excited at this season of life when
you're engaged
to get to have those conversations and
take that class absolutely so stay on
the line kelly's going to
get you that information um and also as
well kelly get their information too
i want to bring them on my show i like
them i like them a lot i want to
interview them on my show as well
because i think young people need to
hear this um
so yeah get their information kelly and
i'm gonna call them personally
and have them come on my show this is
why i get excited about doing a randy
show especially with you christy cause
we just have fun
i want you to bust into this new
marriage or mortgage show and just be
like neither
neither pay off your debt pay at all you
have this like surprise
in all the episodes just you be the
neither guy listen
they don't want me to do that because i
hurt someone's feelings